alain giguère bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être en direct quand un matin sur rtl
france alors racontez nous tout d'abord
vous avez perdu votre emploi l'an
dernier à cause du virus dans quelles
circonstances est couplé cgt chaque de
projets dans une entreprise informatique
et avec des superbes projets qui ont été
imaginés bien sur des détails mais qui
ont été autofinancés au début par les
par l'épreuve parlée par les gérants et
puis je pense qu'ils attendaient des
attendait des financements qui ne sont
pas arrivés
je pense à cause du coc vide on m'a dit
à cause du pot vide et je pense que
c'était ça donc de l'argent qui peut
arriver des financements donc des
financeurs qui d'après moi non pas celui
là donc malheureusement l'été si
longtemps était bien partie elle est
superbe le projet images on a dû se
séparer du séparer tout simplement est
en tout cas très vite vous avez décidé
de monter votre propre affaire pourtant
on imagine que ça paraît risqué puisque
avec le covili a bien évidemment une
baisse de l'activité un bien sûr les
chercher déjà j'ai cherchell et les
endroits de la société qui était en
besoin tu peux donc j'ai vu tous ces
gens qui devaient manger dans leur
camion qui voilà qu'ils quittaient le
travail ou trop tôt ou trop tard qu'il
n'avait n'avait rien pour manger chaud
sur la page chez eux
et puis je me suis dit que tous ces gens
là avaient besoin quelque chose avait
besoin qu'on leur rende à un service et
je me suis orienté vers ses
distributeurs de pizza qui peuvent aussi
distribué par exemple des plats cuisinés
autre chose et ça permettait justement
déjà de rendre ce service est dans une
petite niche qui fonctionnent encore
aujourd'hui
j'espère encore pour un certain temps et
puis voilà donc ça m'a permis de me
lancer il ya pas très longtemps parce
qu'on a démarré notre premier disque dur
rapide à jeudi dernier comptanoo quand
vous vous êtes retrouvé au chômage alors
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'incertitudes à
cause de cette crise sanitaire
dans quel état d'esprit on est comment
avez-vous
anticipé cette situation on en parle
évidemment parce qu'elle réforme de
l'assurance chômage qui se profile vous
ne serez pas concerné a priori mais
comment est ce qu'on vit cette période
compliquée on est un peu on sent un
petit peu perdues alors déjà moi j'étais
c'est la première fois que je me
retrouvais on peut connecter dans cette
situation et bien que je comprenais
vraiment pour quelle raison ça s'était
arrêté
je jetais un petit peu perdu mais assez
rapidement j'ai j'ai réagi en disant
voilà c'est pas ça ne s'arrête pas sur
le sur le présent on avance on vise le
futur puis j'ai les enfants faut que je
travaille pour eux aussi et puis voilà
donc on a ça m'a permis en finale pas
rester pendant quelques semaines ça m'a
plombé un petit peu et puis après assez
rapidement ça m'a permis de rebondir je
suis allé voir les banques qui ont suivi
d'ailleurs je les remercie
et donc ça a été plutôt une aventure
positif ensuite est-ce que vous avez été
pendant cette période en lien avec pôle
emploi qu est ce qu on vous disait alors
comme je vous le disais c'est la
première fois que je veux que je le
retrouvais chi pôle emploi et mais
j'étais plutôt très agréablement surpris
j'ai vraiment des gens qui étaient
attentifs et qu'ils ne cherchaient pas à
me l'envoyer dans un dans un endroit où
dans un autre mais qui sont vraiment
posé la question de ce que je voulais
faire ça combinables sociale
j'avais les projets des vrais projets
ils ont vraiment essayé de réserver ses
ils ont même réussi
enfin ils m'ont accompagné vraiment
plutôt aussi qu'on me tenir le moral
parce qu'en finale je me suis débrouillé
que tout seul avec les banques ça mais
eux ont vraiment été un appui
voilà je maintenant ça s'est très bien
passé et que c'est vous de ces personnes
et notamment les jeunes aujourd'hui qui
ont beaucoup de mal à vous travaillé
dans la restauration aujourd'hui ces
jeunes qui avaient un emploi et qui
n'arrive plus à travailler aujourd'hui
alors j'ai été le très longtemps
restaurateurs etc des gens que je
connais bien pour les avoir pratiquées
pendant très longtemps et je pense que
c'est catastrophique parce que on fait
ce métier là souvent par besoin mais
c'est un métier qu'on aime quand même
parce qu'on
beaucoup de gens ça donne beaucoup
d'opportunités alors je pense que de
rester chez soi même même au chômage
c'est une catastrophe
ces jeunes ont besoin de besoin de vivre
tout simplement
et comment les aider selon vous alors
vous allez trouver une alternative ou en
tant que restaurateur le métier a changé
selon vous le métier va changer non
c'est simplement c'est de la technologie
c'est comme internet un outil des tas de
choses mais là la technologie amène des
nouveautés je pense que c'est des
nouveautés qui s'installe ça changera
rien la restauration habituel
traditionnel où je pense que les bons
restaurateurs les bons restaurants où il
ya une bonne ambiance impôts décor on
sera toujours content de les trouver
par contre aujourd'hui la technologie
permet de respectivement d'accéder à
d'autres moyens de consommer je pense
que c'est pas une bonne c'est vraiment
quelque chose il va se mettre en place
et qui va se confirmer au fil des années
quoi peut-être pour conclure votre
réaction
on le disait dans ce contexte sanitaire
difficile le gouvernement lui maintient
sa réforme de l'assurance chômage
qu'est ce que vous en pensez non mais je
n'ai pas trop d'avis sur la question
honnêtement je préfère me concentrer sur
sur des choses voilà qui me concerne
très directement à dire aujourd'hui
faire lancer mes machines faire plaisir
à mes clients que tout le monde voilà
tout le monde trouve son île qui trouve
son compte et que je puisse aussi moi à
mon tour embaucher un ou deux jeunes
ensuite pour les ferrari
merci beaucoup et on vous souhaite
évidemment tout le succès que vous
méritez merci d'avoir livré ce
témoignage en direct ce matin sur rtl
france